in death George Floyd has made America
take a long hard look at itself and in
Houston a constant stream of people came
to say goodbye
horrified at his last moments humbled by
what he's inspired now returned to the
city where he spent most of his life the
United States has seen centuries of
racism but the Republican governor of
Texas says he feels the winds of change
this is the most horrific tragedy I've
ever personally observed but George
Floyd is going to change the arc of the
future of the United States George Floyd
has not died in vain his life will be a
living legacy about the way that America
in Texas respond to this tragedy in
Minneapolis the police officer who
pressed his knee on George Floyd for
nearly nine minutes appeared in court
for the first time via videolink Derrick
Chauvin is accused of second-degree
murder and second degree manslaughter if
convicted he will face up to 40 years in
prison the City Council there has voted
to disband the police force we will now
kneel for our moment of silence and in
Washington there are more signs of his
shift senior Democrats kneeling in
silence before unveiling a bill that
would ban chokeholds and create a
national registry of officers who have
been accused of misconduct the martyrdom
of George Floyd gay American expert on
experience a moment of national anguish
as we grieve for the black Americans
killed by police brutality today this
movement of NAT moment of national
language is being transformed into a
movement of national action President
Trump though today insisted the police
purse will be protected there will be
defunding the
be dismantling of our police sometimes
you'll see some horrible things like we
witnessed recently but 99 I say 99.9 but
let's go with 99 percent of them great
great people
the reality is demonstrations about the
deaths of black men and women can flare
and fade in this country but this time
does feel different the scale of anger
the sense of momentum unlike anything
we've seen for decades
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington